lcp vous donne rendez vous pour une
grande émission spéciale élections
législatives 2022 toute la chaîne se
mobilise pour vous faire vivre cet
événement plus de quatre heures de
direct pour tout connaître des résultats
découvrir le nouveau visage de
l'assemblée nationale grâce à nos
nombreux correspondants en région un peu
partout en france dans les
circonscriptions clés et en plateau des
politologues des géographes des
constitutionnalistes pour analyser les
résultats et tirer les conséquences de
ce scrutin émission spéciale second tour
des élections législatives présenté par
brigitte boucher et myriam encaoua
dimanche en direct dès 19h30